organe aus dem 3d drucker ist das die
zukunft
nein es ist die gegenwart und dass diese
organe funktionieren wurde jetzt an
künstlichen ruinen von mädchen gezeigt
die ihm bereits vor acht jahren
eingepflanzt wurden ein medizinischer
umbruch jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction
manchmal spielen sich wissenschaftliche
revolutionen im verborgenen ab und die
öffentlichkeit erfährt erst jahre später
wie sich die welt nahezu unbemerkt
verändert hat es ist tatsächlich möglich
organe zu drucken und sie menschen zu
implantieren diese organe arbeiten dann
so als wären sie natürlich gewachsen
vor acht jahren gab es zwar noch keine
3d drucker für organe aber die mediziner
von workforce institut für regenerative
medizin waren in der lage passendes
gewebe für eine vagina von hand zu
modellieren es passte an die
entsprechende stelle im körper und es
enthielt die richtigen zellen um die
funktion einer vagina zu übernehmen
inzwischen gibt es aber diese 3d drucker
und es ist möglich unterschiedlicher
organe aus den unterschiedlichsten
geweben zum truppen rundkurs dabei
bildet das kollagen ein molekül das als
wichtiger bestandteil im körper bei
knochen sehnen muskeln bändern und
autist allen körperteilen die belastbar
sein müssen
es hat dabei eigenschaften wie
kohlefaser und kann bezogen auf die
erdanziehungskraft das 10.000 fache des
eigengewichtes als zugkraft halten
aus diesem eiweiß werden die
grundstrukturen für organe und jedwede
körperteile gefertigt sogar
funktionierende muskeln können daraus
gezüchtet werden bei der künstlichen
vagina wurde genau das von hand getan
auf eine grundstruktur aus kollagen
wurde das passende gewebe für eine
vagina auf beiden seiten aufgetragen und
den brutschrank soweit gezüchtet dass
das gewebe implantiert werden konnte
jetzt nach acht jahren steht fest es
haben sich komplett normale organen
gebildet die vagina funktioniert bei den
mädchen wie bei jedem anderen mädchen
auch grund für die op war bei den
patientinnen eine nicht ausgebildete
beziehungsweise nicht vorhandene wagen
mit dem künstlichen organen können
sie jetzt leben wie jede andere frau
können sex haben und werden erregt es
ist ein spektakulärer start für eine
vollkommen neue ausrichtung der medizin
statt toten organe zu entnehmen die nie
richtig zum immunsystem des
transportierten passen werden zukunft
aus den zellen des patienten passende
organen gezüchtet es gibt so keinerlei
abstoßungsreaktionen und die patienten
müssen nicht mehr ein leben lang
medikamente nehmen die eben eine solche
abstoßungsreaktion verhindern sollen
setzt komplexe organe wie zum beispiel
nieren mit ihren unterschiedlichen
zellen können heute schon im 3 d drucker
gedruckt werden noch sind sie nicht voll
funktionsfähig
aber nach auskunft der wissenschaftler
vom wake forest institute für
regenerative medizin sondern nur noch
ein paar jahre dauern bis sie
funktionieren
dagegen können heute schon ohren nasen
oder auch komplexere organe die blasen
harnröhre und sogar speiseröhren
implantiert werden und die funktionieren
schon bald soll haut auch direkt auf
verbrannte stellen gedruckt werden
können
hier am modell unglaublich was wir alles
möglich ist zb auch dass die dunkle
materie mode aufgespürt wie weshalb
warum
hier oben klicken in der video
beschreibung gibt es natürlich alle
links für smartphones tablets und so
weiter ständig neu news sport
wissenschaft medizin und technik gibt es
im blog
und ich möchte jetzt nur noch eins
wissen was haltet ihr von den im labor
gezüchteten organe diskutiert es in den
kommentaren und ansonsten bis dann nah
dran